No, quick.
NOTE CONF
That's right.
Cover.
NOTE CONF
So that so?
Lets have a look.
NOTE CONF
Look.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Good morning, Isiah.
She's online.
NOTE CONF
Good.
Fine.
NOTE CONF
All right, we're hit.
9.
NOTE CONF
30.
We can begin.
NOTE CONF
You can keep chatting.
No, you You trying to force sort out an issue?
NOTE CONF
Sort it out.
Um, good morning.
NOTE CONF
How are you?
We've got a nod of happiness.
NOTE CONF
We've got a thumbs up and we've got stares of
apathy and boredom from everybody else, which is fine.
NOTE CONF
So we're apathetic and bored.
Yeah, Let's have some fun.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I This is just too much fun.
I don't understand why not.
NOTE CONF
Everyone in the whole world finds this fun to do
on a, um I was reading it on the way
NOTE CONF
in reading it again on the way in.
And I'm like, Oh, it's gonna be so much fun
NOTE CONF
this week.
I mean, every week's fun, but this week's gonna be
NOTE CONF
fun.
OK, so we are on to our two topics this
NOTE CONF
week.
Uh, evaluation and prologue.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we'll get to those in a sec, but let's
start off just by doing a preview with the assignment
NOTE CONF
that been released.
It's a little under two weeks now until it's due
NOTE CONF
So I think it was released with 13 days to
go.
NOTE CONF
So my apologies for not making it 14 days.
Um, I'm considering whether I put another day or two
NOTE CONF
on the due date, but because the uni wants me
to make Sunday nights the due dates for every assessment,
NOTE CONF
I then have to go and fill in some paperwork
or something.
NOTE CONF
Every assessment is supposed to be Sunday night at 1145
or 55 or whatever it is.
NOTE CONF
So if any of your academics set something due on
a Friday night, you should ask them for an extension
NOTE CONF
on Sunday night because it should all be due on
a Sunday night.
NOTE CONF
That was the rules they gave us.
Um, but yeah, it's when it's actually nice and quick.
NOTE CONF
Once you get get, get into it again with all
everything in this course, you gotta get your brain around
NOTE CONF
it.
And then once you get your brain around it, it
NOTE CONF
just should just work out nice and easily.
It's broken up into two kind of levels, uh, implementing
NOTE CONF
these new primitives called Read and Write or Read and
Rand, and you can implement them as a kind of
NOTE CONF
keyword approach with Read and Rand, or you can implement
them as an operator approach with these symbols left arrow
NOTE CONF
and double bang.
And both the scanning and the passing is a bit
NOTE CONF
easier for the the Read and Rand version, and the
scanning and the passing is a bit harder for the
NOTE CONF
arrow and double bang version.
So if you're struggling, just stick to doing the read
NOTE CONF
and Rand version.
Once you've got that working look into doing the bang
NOTE CONF
and Arrow version, and it's not conceptually harder, it's just
you gotta go to just the code that ends up
NOTE CONF
going in touches a few more places for the the
second versions and the first versions.
NOTE CONF
We just gotta scan them and pause them.
And but there's 11 trick is that for us to
NOTE CONF
mark this assignment, we have to be able to mark
the scanning separately from the passing so you can't just
NOTE CONF
use your standard locks interpreter.
We've had to provide a small change to the locks
NOTE CONF
interpreter, and the change we've provided is exactly on top
of what would come out of the Week five code.
NOTE CONF
If you were just following along with the book so
Oh, my goodness.
NOTE CONF
Stuff flying everywhere.
There we go.
NOTE CONF
So I've got a directory here that's got exactly what
the book has told me.
NOTE CONF
If I just copied and pasted everything over from the
book to Week five.
NOTE CONF
If that's your starting point, then you'll be able to
make the changes directly the way we've shown you.
NOTE CONF
But we've shown them in a form that you can
make those changes on any code base.
NOTE CONF
So if you've got your version that's slightly different, that's
fine.
NOTE CONF
You can start from that as well.
All it has to do is get the input and
NOTE CONF
the output, right.
We're only checking input and output in this assignment.
NOTE CONF
Uh, we don't need all that junk bear, but just
as an example, this is the locks reader that comes
NOTE CONF
out of the S, the ST the book, But this
in week five.
NOTE CONF
The book always scans and pauses, so you can't see
the scanner output anymore.
NOTE CONF
You can only see the Parsa output, and so we
wanna be able to give you grades if you manage
NOTE CONF
to get the scanner to work but not the Parsa
to work.
NOTE CONF
So we make a small adjustment um a An example
of where we make the adjustment here is on in
NOTE CONF
this section where public void Maine, the existing one wants
either one argument or zero arguments.
NOTE CONF
If you give it two arguments, it complains and says,
no, no, I can only work with one argument or
NOTE CONF
zero arguments if you give me one argument.
Um, if you give me more, I'll complain.
NOTE CONF
If you give me one, I'll run it on that
file.
NOTE CONF
And if you give me zero, I'll run the the
rebel, right?
NOTE CONF
So I think I need syntax locks.
Whereas if you make these small changes here, you say
NOTE CONF
if the ARS is greater than two given error, if
the ARS is equal to two, use the first one
NOTE CONF
to tell me which phase I'm output and the second
one is the file.
NOTE CONF
If you give me just one argument, I'm gonna treat
it as a file.
NOTE CONF
And if you give me zero arguments, I'm gonna run
the report and then add that phase parameter a phase
NOTE CONF
field here and make use of it properly below.
You can get what we've got on our version, which
NOTE CONF
are the same.
Um, well, you get what we've got on our version,
NOTE CONF
which allows you to instead of I'm just trying to
wonder where my locks is.
NOTE CONF
OK?
Um yeah, was to say directly So I put that
NOTE CONF
in the syntax directory.
So J AC syntax star dot Java compiles and Java
NOTE CONF
minus CP dot slash syntax dot locks.
Right.
NOTE CONF
That's how I run the programme.
So if I run that with no arguments, I get
NOTE CONF
the interpreter version.
If I run that with one argument, it tries to
NOTE CONF
use that as a file and complains for some reason
Ah, cos that file doesn't exist, I should have told
NOTE CONF
it.
OK, so it runs a lock file.
NOTE CONF
But if I give it two arguments, it treats the
first one as the phase to run and the second
NOTE CONF
one as the file name.
So this allows us to run your assignments where we
NOTE CONF
put scan in for the first time we run it
and we put pas in for the second time we
NOTE CONF
run it and your assignment should output the scanner output
if we put scan in there and the pas are
NOTE CONF
output.
If we put pas in there and we've got that's
NOTE CONF
exactly what we do in our script to run your
assignments.
NOTE CONF
So we've shown that in the spec here.
This is exactly how we're gonna run your assignment.
NOTE CONF
So make sure it's in the right package with that
name.
NOTE CONF
Make sure when we put scan in as the first
argument, we get the scanner output.
NOTE CONF
When we put powers in as the second one, we
get the power output and just for fun.
NOTE CONF
And you can make the changes to your code to
do that yourself in any way you want.
NOTE CONF
But here are the diff instructions for converting the Week
five code into a code that does that.
NOTE CONF
So a diff is where you take two versions of
a programme.
NOTE CONF
You run it through diff and it spits out exactly
the difference.
NOTE CONF
Diff is also a programme.
You can take a diff from someone else and patch
NOTE CONF
your code with it so someone else can say, Oh,
I've got a slightly different version of your code, send
NOTE CONF
you just the diff, and you can apply that to
your code and get a different version.
NOTE CONF
Version control systems are built around diffs, and they're a
very important part of programming.
NOTE CONF
So I thought it might just be a fun way
to show you these changes.
NOTE CONF
You can.
If you know how to use DS, you can apply
NOTE CONF
them directly.
If you know how to read DS, you can do
NOTE CONF
them by hand.
And I'll just quickly summarise what this diff is actually
NOTE CONF
saying.
OK, now all of this is happening on a single
NOTE CONF
file.
It's just on the locks dot Java file, and this
NOTE CONF
tiff is saying Line 12.
Add 1/13 line and make it look like this.
NOTE CONF
This one says Line 15 says change.
Make it line 16 Cos we've added a line above.
NOTE CONF
Change it from this to this This one says, Take
the original Line 18 and change it so that now
NOTE CONF
lines 19 to 23.
It used to be this on line 18.
NOTE CONF
Now it's lines this on 18 to 23.
So I was telling you what to put in what
NOTE CONF
to take out to change your file and you can
just go through.
NOTE CONF
And one way to read it is you go Oh,
where there was ars length two.
NOTE CONF
I put Ar's length greater than two.
Where there was ars length equals why I put this
NOTE CONF
whole block, so on and so forth.
But you're making those changes yourself to get your compiler
NOTE CONF
up and running.
But you can do it off your version that you've
NOTE CONF
built over five weeks.
You can do it off a copy from the book.
NOTE CONF
That is exactly the same out of those five weeks,
Um, and you can read the code that we've done
NOTE CONF
here, right?
So I said that when the phase equals scan, I
NOTE CONF
just want you to print out each token.
When the phase is equal to pars, I want you
NOTE CONF
to run the parser and use the A ST printer
to print the expression.
NOTE CONF
And I said in the assessment, I'd like you to
just keep the original a ST pas up.
NOTE CONF
Um, but we've also got a set of input output
examples that show you exactly what your output should look
NOTE CONF
like for different inputs.
OK, so if your input was, uh to open the
NOTE CONF
cell directory, maybe why aren't you dragging of Brokenness?
There we go.
NOTE CONF
Well, you're not gonna open them.
I put all the examples in here Anyway, if your
NOTE CONF
input was the number one, just a single expression one.
The output of your scan phase should be exactly this
NOTE CONF
string.
The output of your PAS phase should be exactly this
NOTE CONF
string.
And so you've got the input outputs for a bunch
NOTE CONF
of examples.
If the input expression is one plus two, the output
NOTE CONF
of the scan phase should be this.
The output of PAS phase should be this.
NOTE CONF
And then we've got examples for the random and read
as well.
NOTE CONF
If your input is one plus rand, then your output
for the scan should be this.
NOTE CONF
Make sure yours matches that and your output for the
powers should be this.
NOTE CONF
OK, so we're just running.
We're gonna grade this one with auto grading.
NOTE CONF
We're gonna pump it through a script and the script
is gonna say Yep, no, they matched or they didn't
NOTE CONF
match.
We'll apply some human like look at when it doesn't
NOTE CONF
match.
But mostly you're just gonna get the results of the
NOTE CONF
script.
So just make sure your input outputs match scanning and
NOTE CONF
pausing Happy, happy, happy days.
OK, so with that in mind, we'll do a little
NOTE CONF
review of scanning and passing today, but mostly into evaluation.
But really, I'm I'm putting evaluation into context as well
NOTE CONF
here today.
So questions on that?
NOTE CONF
Yep.
Yeah, something to be figured out.
NOTE CONF
You know that.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
I can never promise times, but it shouldn't be too
long.
NOTE CONF
So part of this is that we're giving you very
specific instructions on how to submit.
NOTE CONF
Like your what script?
We're gonna run to, uh, check your programme.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna be testing this on Linux and Mac.
So the actual script we'll run is this one unless
NOTE CONF
we find errors and we have to update it.
But this is the script We plan to run now.
NOTE CONF
This doesn't work exactly like this on a windows powershell.
So we've got to just double check the windows powershell
NOTE CONF
version.
Um, but it's I think there might be zero difference.
NOTE CONF
I gotta double check on a powershell.
Um, but whatever you do on Powershell to do the
NOTE CONF
same as what this would be, it's just the same.
So the main The key, I guess, is making sure
NOTE CONF
one key to making sure yours works is that when
you unzip the zip file, it creates a syntax directory.
NOTE CONF
Too many people will unzip their zip file and just
dump all the files right there.
NOTE CONF
and it won't be in a syntax directory, which means
means it's not valid to be in a syntax package,
NOTE CONF
which means my Java compiler can compile and run it.
So I also said that we'll we'll sort out a
NOTE CONF
session where we're gonna all drop in together, and we
can all try out each other's submissions to make sure
NOTE CONF
that we're confident they're working according to the scripts.
And probably that'll be in the drop in Centre in
NOTE CONF
the Thursday Friday before it's due or something.
So even if you're not completed with the assignment, you
NOTE CONF
can be completed on making sure you've got your submission
set up like you know how to zip it correctly
NOTE CONF
so that it unzips the way we need it.
Yep, and it really is just a case of right
NOTE CONF
click compress folder at the right place in your file
system.
NOTE CONF
Like we know there's nothing fancy here, but we just
wanna give everyone a chance to get it right.
NOTE CONF
OK, questions, other questions.
And if anyone decides they know how to make that
NOTE CONF
work in Windows, you can show me Now I can
put your script up cos one of the reasons it's
NOTE CONF
not up yet is I don't have a Windows computer
to test on handy.
NOTE CONF
OK, cool, Cool, cool.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
All right, let's do some expression.
Well, some evaluating.
NOTE CONF
Well, first, let's Orient reorient ourselves.
That's pretty much all I all I like to do
NOTE CONF
in lectures is reorient.
So let's reorient.
NOTE CONF
Uh, my voice is gonna be a bit funny and
I apologise.
NOTE CONF
Let's get over to the visualizer and again shout out
if I'm talking about if I go back to talking
NOTE CONF
about the code while I'm still showing the visualizer Oh,
that's not good.
NOTE CONF
OK, so, uh, let's start with a relatively simple example.
Um, I'm always doing the same examples ever again.
NOTE CONF
So maybe I should do a different one.
What's a a different example?
NOTE CONF
Let's do bullion this time.
So I've got the locks.
NOTE CONF
I've got the lox expression.
So we know the true Zollo expression and so is
NOTE CONF
true.
Or oh, that's a locks expression.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, Now we know what we think that should evaluate
to That should evaluate to true because we know how
NOTE CONF
Os work.
But let's just go through the process.
NOTE CONF
The syntax analyzer first goes through, so the yeah, the
scanner first goes through and turns this into a token
NOTE CONF
stream for me.
Maybe I should do colours.
NOTE CONF
How cool would that be?
And the scanner should make a list of tokens.
NOTE CONF
We'll have the true token.
We'll have the A token and we'll have the false
NOTE CONF
taken.
And then the Parsa is gonna go through that, and
NOTE CONF
it's going to create the A new binary expression.
So this one's a binary expression.
NOTE CONF
It was a binary operator.
Binary operator.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, binary operator.
And it's gonna have two Children, one of which is
NOTE CONF
the true, which is down as a literal and the
false, which is down as a literal.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So a couple of key things to point out here,
NOTE CONF
Up here in blue, we've just got a set of
characters Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun TRUE, space, blah,
NOTE CONF
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So these were this was a string.
NOTE CONF
Or maybe we might think of it as a a
list of characters if we wanted to.
NOTE CONF
When the scanner created it, we had to create this
new object type called token.
NOTE CONF
That was a class, and each of these this was
a list of tokens, right?
NOTE CONF
And we kept track of some fields in token, that
I think are useful to look at.
NOTE CONF
I know I'm looking at my code right now, but
it's just to remind me of what's in token.
NOTE CONF
And so the token class.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
What do you want to get?
The token class was keeping track of a token type,
NOTE CONF
Alex an object and in which was mine.
Now, I don't know about you, but I can't understand
NOTE CONF
this system without a diagram like this.
I've harped on about it before, and I'm gonna continue
NOTE CONF
to harp on about it because I, I can hear
that a lot of people are getting lost in understanding
NOTE CONF
the system as a whole.
And probably the reason you're not understanding the system as
NOTE CONF
a whole is you're not sitting down and making your
own version of this diagram from scratch that matches your
NOTE CONF
own cognitive processes, your own internalised understanding of the system.
So I'm showing you mine.
NOTE CONF
But you don't then write down mine and go good.
I've got maths one.
NOTE CONF
So now I understand.
I only wrote that out to support my own cognition.
NOTE CONF
And so you should be writing out your version to
support your cognition and maybe it'll look a lot like
NOTE CONF
mine because I'm good at this and maybe it'll look
like other things, but I couldn't like even when I
NOTE CONF
walked in as someone who's written a dozen passes and
invented a programming language.
NOTE CONF
Even as I walked in, I went, Ah, the relationship
between all these parts is still a bit fuzzy to
NOTE CONF
me, and so I'm writing them down partly so that
I can be confident in moving forward.
NOTE CONF
Don't pretend like you can be confident of any of
this without diagrammatic support for your cognitive processes.
NOTE CONF
And so you'll see that again in this week's workshop.
I want you to submit a picture you drew of
NOTE CONF
how the evaluation works, Um, which we'll do in class.
Alright.
NOTE CONF
So that that kind of U and Mellish notation I've
done up here for the token is quite helpful because
NOTE CONF
that's just the things I need to know about the
token.
NOTE CONF
To make sense out of it.
It's got the token type.
NOTE CONF
That's the thing I'm really doing over here with the
true or and false.
NOTE CONF
So there's a little bit more information stored in there,
in particular, Lexi in the back of my head.
NOTE CONF
I go I know the literal for true is true
And the literal for false is false and literal for
NOTE CONF
or is null cos null doesn't have a literal And
I maybe start to realise that this literal field over
NOTE CONF
here in the token really only makes sense for the
literal nodes down here.
NOTE CONF
Uh, but I put it in for today, OK?
And each of these nodes came from in the Parsa
NOTE CONF
came from this expression type, which had so the expression
time, I don't think, didn't have any interesting fields of
NOTE CONF
its own.
But it did have this accept method because it's a
NOTE CONF
visitor.
And then from the accept method, I subtyped a bunch
NOTE CONF
of others that actually had interesting themes.
Literal.
NOTE CONF
Finally, up you re up and there was one more,
which was grouping, right.
NOTE CONF
Cool.
Uh, that's my system.
NOTE CONF
Happy.
So if I wanna go now, we're up to evaluation.
NOTE CONF
So that's all the context we're gonna need.
Um, let's just look at this concrete example for how
NOTE CONF
evaluation might work.
This is another hot tip for doing programming language stuff.
NOTE CONF
Understanding what's going on at the abstract level can be
quite difficult.
NOTE CONF
It can be really helpful just to get yourself a
small example and trace out what's going on with that
NOTE CONF
small example that starts to build the intuition that creates
the in the abstract model.
NOTE CONF
So even without me reading anything of the text, I
might ask myself, I'll use, um red for evaluation.
NOTE CONF
How on earth am I gonna evaluate something that's my
next stage?
NOTE CONF
Right, I got evaluator.
What's an evaluator gonna do?
NOTE CONF
I have to guess if it's recursively.
That's right.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, you've got the right answer.
So the answer was, If it's literal, I just get
NOTE CONF
the value of that literal.
And if it's something else, I'd recursively work out the
NOTE CONF
Children.
But if I go a little bit deeper on that
NOTE CONF
and just think I've got a clue over here, right?
The The clue is I already know that for acting
NOTE CONF
on these trees, I generally traverse the trees.
I've got a visit, a pattern for a reason.
NOTE CONF
So I'm probably going to visit the tree as I
go along.
NOTE CONF
So I might just put the tree in the original
scan tree the pastry.
NOTE CONF
Sorry and think What's an evaluator gonna do?
So if an evaluator came in at the top of
NOTE CONF
the tree.
Oops, cheese colour.
NOTE CONF
The evaluator comes in at the top of the tree.
It might ask itself, What's the value of this tree?
NOTE CONF
So that's another thing to keep in mind.
Evaluators take.
NOTE CONF
This is a good point, actually, To make further up
here, the scanner took in a character stream and gave
NOTE CONF
back a token stream.
The parser took in a token stream and gave back
NOTE CONF
a parse tree.
The evaluator takes I'm giving you a preview.
NOTE CONF
The evaluator takes in a pars tree and spits out
a value just one value, which is the result of
NOTE CONF
the programme.
Every programme has one result.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, well, every expression has one result.
Remember, here we're just stuck in expression name.
NOTE CONF
We haven't looked at statements yet and we know that
expressions are things that can be evaluated to a value.
NOTE CONF
When we look at a programme that's got statements, we
might think our evaluator has to do something more than
NOTE CONF
just turn a past tree into a value.
But for now, the past tree is definitely an expression,
NOTE CONF
so it definitely can be turned into a value.
So we might ask.
NOTE CONF
So what's the value of this thing?
And you should say to yourself, I can't answer the
NOTE CONF
value of that note unless I know the value of
its Children.
NOTE CONF
So I will defer that and I will visit its
Children and I'll try down here.
NOTE CONF
And I say, What's the value of that?
And I go, Oh, that's easy.
NOTE CONF
The value of that is true.
Um, and so I know that one.
NOTE CONF
I can send that one back up but finished over
here.
NOTE CONF
I still can't finish this one until I know the
answer.
NOTE CONF
This one, the value of that one is false.
And I go, OK, I know that one sent it
NOTE CONF
back.
And now I can work out the value of true
NOTE CONF
or false, and I can send back the value.
True.
NOTE CONF
So in that process, by tracing that in this, if
I showed you this diagram, you'd be you had no
NOTE CONF
idea what was going on.
But by following what I did, the diagram is some
NOTE CONF
representation.
Gee, these colours aren't working out very well on that
NOTE CONF
screen, are they?
They look so good on mine.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I can track a few things about the way
this evaluator had to go.
NOTE CONF
If I number each node it had to do it
visited one.
NOTE CONF
They went in on one, but it couldn't come back
out of one until it had also gone in on
NOTE CONF
two and come out of two gone in on three
come out of three.
NOTE CONF
And now we could come out of one.
And this is the classic visitor pattern.
NOTE CONF
So it's just a case of saying that's what visitor
pattern does.
NOTE CONF
It says I'd like to do this at all the
different nodes, so I'm gonna be using that accept pattern
NOTE CONF
over here.
But the other thing I recognise is that the values
NOTE CONF
filtered from the bottom.
The first place in a Val a value appeared was
NOTE CONF
there.
Then the second place was there and then finally up
NOTE CONF
there and so something I want you to get in
your head is that even when our traversal goes in
NOTE CONF
at the top, the values the results might be filtering
up from the bottom.
NOTE CONF
OK?
And that's what they mentioned in the book as a
NOTE CONF
post order traversal instead of a preorder traversal.
Um but I can think of it as bottom up
NOTE CONF
calculation, but I do need a process that goes in
at the top and kind of delays itself as it
NOTE CONF
progresses all the way down the tree.
And then when it gets to the bottom of the
NOTE CONF
tree, it starts to unroll itself back to an answer.
So this all feels very complicated until you realise, you
NOTE CONF
just think back to your comp 2010 and go.
That's just what a recursive traversal of a tree does.
NOTE CONF
All I'm really doing here is a recursive traversal of
a tree.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna rewrite all this.
Um, I'll rub that out and start again, but I
NOTE CONF
show you that because I want the magic of the
recursive traversal to disappear.
NOTE CONF
So we've still got these abstract in text tree there
we're gonna work on.
NOTE CONF
But what I wanna do is I wanna do oh
dot evaluate.
NOTE CONF
I want that to be some function, and I wanna
make sure that all dot evaluate function calls left dot
NOTE CONF
evaluate and gets an answer, and it calls right dot
evaluate and gets an answer.
NOTE CONF
And then I want the final answer to be return
out for a better OK, and so that looks exactly
NOTE CONF
like the lines I drew before, but now we can
see that they're just function calls.
NOTE CONF
So all we gotta do is build our evaluator so
that it traverses the tree in the right order and
NOTE CONF
at each of the different nodes, it does the right
thing.
NOTE CONF
Now, remembering that we've got literals, binary ops, unary, ops
and groupings.
NOTE CONF
Our job becomes writing the accept method for each of
these different types of nodes.
NOTE CONF
So the accept method for the literal node it's gonna
be very easy because it always just gives back whatever
NOTE CONF
value is in that literal node which we know he's
actually up there already captured.
NOTE CONF
So that's quite an easy one.
That's just gonna be a single line like something like
NOTE CONF
the time Li for that part of the evaluator for
a binary op.
NOTE CONF
It's always going to do the left evaluate and the
right evaluate like I just did.
NOTE CONF
Then, um, and then it's gonna have to do a
little bit of work just to work out what operation
NOTE CONF
to apply there.
If the binary operator is plus it returns alpha plus
NOTE CONF
beta.
If the binary operator is negative, it does right.
NOTE CONF
The binary operator is all it does alpha or beta
so on and so forth.
NOTE CONF
UNARY operator is gonna be the same thing, except it's
not gonna have a left and a right to work
NOTE CONF
on.
It's only gonna have one, so it'll have to evaluate
NOTE CONF
the thing inside it.
And then, if it's a bang, it'll have to negate
NOTE CONF
it.
If it's a minus, it'll have to well negate it
NOTE CONF
in the mathematical sense.
Um, and then finally, over here on the grouping node,
NOTE CONF
let's have a look at a grouping one just to
think about what that's gonna look like.
NOTE CONF
If my calculation is one plus two plus three like
this, I've ended up with a syntax tree that looks
NOTE CONF
like it's got a plus.
Oops!
NOTE CONF
And on the left it's got a literal one, and
on the right, it's got a grouping, and in the
NOTE CONF
grouping it's got a plus, and the literal to that
are all straight.
NOTE CONF
That's the past tree that comes out of that, and
I've done this as a concrete example because I have
NOTE CONF
trouble thinking about groupings just as an abstract concept.
But once I see one in here, I notice a
NOTE CONF
few important things about it.
it's got one child.
NOTE CONF
The value of the grouping is exactly the value of
the child.
NOTE CONF
So I can see that I'm always just gonna do
you know, child dot evaluate.
NOTE CONF
Whenever I see a grouping, all I do is just
go to one's child and just say, Well, my my
NOTE CONF
value is whatever its value is, I'm just passing it
further up the tree questions, dots.
NOTE CONF
But you should have questions right now because this is
all the theory.
NOTE CONF
Everything now it's just implementing.
Now we just look at Java code that does what
NOTE CONF
we just said.
So if we don't understand what we just said, we're
NOTE CONF
not gonna understand the Java code.
There must be something we don't understand.
NOTE CONF
No stupid questions.
Someone asked me a question.
NOTE CONF
Nothing.
Oh, I'll check online.
NOTE CONF
No questions online either.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
OK, so as I say, the rest of it is
just implementing that.
NOTE CONF
So I guess through some implementation details, and one is
that to make clear that and I've done it with
NOTE CONF
the colours here to make clear that a literal true
is different than a value true, Uh, because when my
NOTE CONF
evaluator did this on this particular example, I got on
this particular example?
NOTE CONF
I got F there.
True there.
NOTE CONF
I got 30, false equals.
True.
NOTE CONF
So the evaluator remember that evaluating goes from past tree
to value.
NOTE CONF
I'm drawing my values in red.
So when I asked for the whole pars tree value,
NOTE CONF
I got back True.
But in the process, I had to ask for the
NOTE CONF
left hand literals value and I got true.
And in the process, I had to ask for the
NOTE CONF
right hand trees value and I got false.
But at every step, I was just asking a tree
NOTE CONF
for its value.
Down here, my tree just happened to be a single
NOTE CONF
node, whereas up here my tree was a more complicated
tree.
NOTE CONF
But it's the same process.
I'm just asking the tree, What's your value?
NOTE CONF
So that's what the evaluators doing.
That's what this evaluate function has to do.
NOTE CONF
But we do want to see that just like the
true character, stream was different from the true token, which
NOTE CONF
was different from the literal node holding true.
These are all separate things in our Java.
NOTE CONF
They've all got different classes attached to them.
It's also different from the actual value true and the
NOTE CONF
The point the note makes here is that the book
makes here is that once we get to value land,
NOTE CONF
I'm not gonna have a value type.
I made my own token type.
NOTE CONF
I made my own a ST nodes, but it didn't
make my own string cos the string was just fine.
NOTE CONF
And I'm not making my own value because the object
from Java is just fine.
NOTE CONF
Um, and some people go Oh, no, The object is
not gonna work because objects are only for, uh, not
NOTE CONF
for primitive types like bullions.
But in Java, every primitive type has a boxed version
NOTE CONF
of that type.
So we can just use that, Which is why I
NOTE CONF
use the capital T truth instead of the lower case
T.
NOTE CONF
So we've gone string of characters, string of token types.
We invented the token types string of abstract syntax tree
NOTE CONF
nodes.
We invented the abstract syntax tree nodes to single value,
NOTE CONF
which is definitely just an object.
So now I know the signature of this evaluate function.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna be object value eight.
Now, I could think of it as having an input
NOTE CONF
of an a ST tree.
Uh, it's a lower case, isn't it?
NOTE CONF
Oh, no, it's just an expression.
Sorry.
NOTE CONF
They use the term we got.
We got the note expression for this.
NOTE CONF
Hey, I could think of it as having an input
of expression.
NOTE CONF
So it's gonna take an expression, give me back an
object, but we're We're an object on the land, so
NOTE CONF
we don't do that.
We go over to the expression class and we make
NOTE CONF
ourselves a evaluate method on that class.
So it's actually evaluate.
NOTE CONF
Don't take in anything.
Give me back an object, But you are an expression
NOTE CONF
object, So I'm actually asking you to evaluate yourself.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
So that's what we gotta write that evaluate function.
It's gonna have to be recursive.
NOTE CONF
It's gonna call, evaluate in other places.
And, uh, Bob Gianni's special friend.
NOTE CONF
OK, let's look at my test.
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
Now I've gone first for that evaluate function and then
said, Theoretically, we're gonna need an evaluate function, but the
NOTE CONF
book goes straight into the, um, the visitor.
But I wanna show you what my evaluate actually looks
NOTE CONF
like.
Oh, no, He has done evaluate in the, um, interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Ok, so cool.
So they didn't put a value over there.
NOTE CONF
Ignore me.
So we're gonna need something that takes an expression.
NOTE CONF
Oh, I gotta switch back over.
So that was another design choice, and I'd forgotten that
NOTE CONF
he went down a different path.
Um, we want something that takes in an expression and
NOTE CONF
gives back an object we actually know.
That's already a visitor.
NOTE CONF
So we're expecting this always to just be the EX
PR dot Except this.
NOTE CONF
So just run the visitor where the visitor is an
evaluation visitor, not a AST visitor.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So let me go back to the A ST thing
NOTE CONF
to remind you of that bit cos that that rolls
in here.
NOTE CONF
OK, so I'm gonna I just want to orient myself
for green up.
NOTE CONF
So the other thing that was missing over here, that
I I slightly left out in my diagram to make
NOTE CONF
things simpler was I just said, accept as the visitor.
But let's be a bit more precise, because what's actually
NOTE CONF
happening is inside every single one of these expressions is
a tiny little interface for visitor.
NOTE CONF
And it has all the different visit methods, right?
Yeah.
NOTE CONF
So that was built into our expression class.
And we reminded ourselves of how the a.
NOTE CONF
The visitor pattern worked to make that understandable.
And then when we wrote the a ST printer, which
NOTE CONF
was one of our things over here in the passing
section that extended, and it actually extends this thing inside
NOTE CONF
here it's an extension of my a ST visitor that's
got each of the methods defined.
NOTE CONF
So it's got visit binary.
So a reminder orienting ourselves again the expression had inside
NOTE CONF
it an interface.
That interface was the visitor that told you, if you
NOTE CONF
ever want to visit expressions, this is how you do
it.
NOTE CONF
And we built some of the machinery on the expression
side.
NOTE CONF
The machinery on the expression side was, when you want
to visit a binary node, Um, hang on.
NOTE CONF
Ah, when you want to visit a binary node, call
its visit binary expression.
NOTE CONF
And when you wanna visit a grouping node, call its
visit grouping expression.
NOTE CONF
Um, and when you visit a literal node called its
visit literal expression, that's all.
NOTE CONF
So that was part of the machinery.
And then the rest of the machinery was over on
NOTE CONF
the visitor itself, where we said, Well, if you're visiting
a binary expression, this is exactly what I want you
NOTE CONF
to do and so you can see cos I'm visiting
a binary expression.
NOTE CONF
I can look at the left and right and do
some things with it when you visit a grouping expression.
NOTE CONF
This is exactly what I want you to do when
you're visiting A.
NOTE CONF
So the a ST node is one of these visitors
that prints the node.
NOTE CONF
We need to create another visitor that evaluates the node
instead.
NOTE CONF
So we're gonna define another thing that extends from this
interface.
NOTE CONF
Mm.
Which is how interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Ok, OK, so if this one's also extending the thing,
then it also has to have visit binary visit un
NOTE CONF
is that grouping and does it?
I don't come and what we're really trying to say.
NOTE CONF
Oh, sorry, I got to put over.
So I just wrote this guy.
NOTE CONF
So we just inherited another visitor.
But this one's called the interpreter, and it's got the
NOTE CONF
visit, binary visit, whatever.
But on these visit binary visit whatevers, we're gonna be
NOTE CONF
doing the evaluation, and that's what we're gonna call our
entire interpreter.
NOTE CONF
It's just a visitor now.
I could The the trick with that is that I've
NOTE CONF
gotta know which node I'm visiting.
So it's nice to have a kind of overriding method
NOTE CONF
that's actually not officially part of the visitor.
Just that does evaluation and says, Oh, whatever you are
NOTE CONF
just run the visitor for this thing.
So the object evaluate we had to write just becomes
NOTE CONF
EX PR dot accept.
What are we accepting?
NOTE CONF
Accepting this visitor?
The visitor we're defining right now the interpreter visitor Because
NOTE CONF
remember that the accept function is how you get a
visitor into an expression.
NOTE CONF
If we did expression dot accept a ST visitor, all
the a ST printing stuff would happen.
NOTE CONF
When we do expression dot accept an interpreter visitor.
All the interpreting stuff happens.
NOTE CONF
So we've just put that method into the interpreter and
said, Ah, right When someone wants to run an interpreter,
NOTE CONF
they could either do expression dot accept new interpreter or
they could do new interpreter and then interpreter dot evaluate.
NOTE CONF
We've gone with the second one.
All right, there's the machinery and hopefully you'll be like,
NOTE CONF
OK, the machinery is the hard part.
Everything else is easy.
NOTE CONF
I can write each of those visits super easy.
So go on.
NOTE CONF
When I'm visiting the literal expression, just give back the
value.
NOTE CONF
I gotta go find the right place, right?
I know I'm dealing with a literal node.
NOTE CONF
I remember it's a literal abstract syntax tree node.
So I go look inside the abstract syntax tree node
NOTE CONF
for literal to find out what fields are available.
And I find there's a value field and I'm like,
NOTE CONF
That's the one I want, obviously.
So I just return it.
NOTE CONF
When I'm doing grouping expressions, I say.
Yep, it's a grouping expression.
NOTE CONF
I just want to return whatever's inside it.
Let's go check what fields it has available.
NOTE CONF
It has a field called expression, which is its only
child, so we can just Well, we can't just return
NOTE CONF
that expression.
Cos that's another syntax tree node.
NOTE CONF
We've gotta try evaluating that.
We put through another interpreter on top of that one
NOTE CONF
and say, Go, go do your interpreter job on that
node.
NOTE CONF
So this is our recursive call, and that's where our
evaluate function.
NOTE CONF
That's why he's now.
He's defining the valuate function.
NOTE CONF
We already did it because we wanted to see the
big picture unary expressions.
NOTE CONF
When we look inside a unitary expression, we're gonna find
it's got a single field called right, which is its
NOTE CONF
child, and we'll evaluate that to find out what the
value of its child is.
NOTE CONF
But we have to do more work after that because
a a unary operator means something.
NOTE CONF
So we take whatever it calculated and then do.
The Unary operator, the Uner operator, was a minus.
NOTE CONF
We do a minus.
If the unary operator was a bang, we invent it.
NOTE CONF
But we're getting little by little.
The details of how the language works start to creep
NOTE CONF
into what we have to do, because when we ask
ourselves, what does it mean to do the negative of
NOTE CONF
a value we got?
Well, we gotta convert it to a number so we
NOTE CONF
can negate it.
So we're assuming it was a number, and I can
NOTE CONF
if I passed minus false, something's gonna go wrong right
here.
NOTE CONF
But let's just Yeah, a runtime error will occur here.
We could have done the same thing.
NOTE CONF
We could have just put a bang operator in, and
then it would only have worked for a true or
NOTE CONF
a false, and we would have got a runtime error
for something else.
NOTE CONF
But at this point, he says, No, no, no No,
no, no.
NOTE CONF
Like the not operator, actually, in most languages works on
more than just true and false Because people love to
NOTE CONF
do ifs on things that aren't true or false in
particular, I'd like to check if you know, you say
NOTE CONF
if on a string you really mean is the string
empty?
NOTE CONF
If you say if on an object Do you mean
is it non null?
NOTE CONF
You say if on a bullion you mean true or
false.
NOTE CONF
But because of the old C programmers, we even like
to say if on integers where zero means false and
NOTE CONF
everything else means true So we want to allow this
on way more than just bullions.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna introduce this function that that codifies what
I mean by something you can do a bang on
NOTE CONF
something and and it's not a bullion.
And so we need another word for it.
NOTE CONF
And they tend to use the word truth.
So values that aren't strictly booleans but can be treated
NOTE CONF
like booleans are truth values.
They're not.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, And so he discusses what his decisions are for
truth truthiness and ends up saying that if it's null,
NOTE CONF
that's false.
If it's an instance of bullying.
NOTE CONF
Then you just do whatever the bullion is for the
truthiness, true or false for everything else, it's just gonna
NOTE CONF
be true.
Any number, any string are gonna be true.
NOTE CONF
So now I can do a bang operator on a,
uh, on a number or a string or anything.
NOTE CONF
And that's his decision about the semantics of his language.
There were a million other choices there that he talked
NOTE CONF
about a little bit, and so that's an extra function
we need along the way that goes in the interpreter.
NOTE CONF
Am I projecting the right thing?
Which one am I projecting?
NOTE CONF
I'm still projecting the visualizer, uh, sorry.
People online.
NOTE CONF
Um, there's a So there's an extra helper function he
needs for doing that, and that goes inside the interpreter
NOTE CONF
as well.
Binary expressions are exactly what we said.
NOTE CONF
That was my alpha and beta.
He just evaluates, left and evaluates right to find out
NOTE CONF
what's in them.
And then he has to go through for each of
NOTE CONF
the different type of operators that might be in that
node.
NOTE CONF
Make them work the way they're supposed to.
So if it's a minus, you're gonna treat that like
NOTE CONF
a number and minus it.
And we should be thinking to ourselves, we've got a
NOTE CONF
cast in here.
Something could go wrong.
NOTE CONF
The parser could have passed true, minus false.
What's gonna happen when that happens?
NOTE CONF
Um, he also notes that, uh, something we talked about
in earlier lectures Where, uh, earlier workshops.
NOTE CONF
I think it was Where what order are things evaluated
in is actually part of the language.
NOTE CONF
Semantics.
Um, up until now, there's been no definitive rule for
NOTE CONF
if you have one plus two, do you calculate one
first or do you calculate two first?
NOTE CONF
Now we know for sure.
We're gonna calculate the left one first and then the
NOTE CONF
right one cos that's the order there being done right
here.
NOTE CONF
OK, there's a couple more operators here, and he starts
to kick in with these checks.
NOTE CONF
And this is the same operator, but no minus.
Oh, with plus, when he gets to Plus, he realises,
NOTE CONF
plus, op works differently on strings versus numbers.
So we've known that in the back of our head,
NOTE CONF
but we've just been writing it, and the PA has
just been passing it, and it's just gone.
NOTE CONF
Number plus number or string, plus string or string plus
number and just let it go through.
NOTE CONF
At this point, the evaluator has to say, If I've
got string String, I know what to do.
NOTE CONF
If I've got number number, I know what to do
If I've got something else, I don't know what to
NOTE CONF
do If I've got string number, I don't know what
to do If I've got number String, I don't know
NOTE CONF
what to do So he pulls out those two He
says, Oh, well, look at left and find out are
NOTE CONF
both of those doubles Then I'm gonna do the the
number version.
NOTE CONF
If both there's a string, I'm gonna do the string
version.
NOTE CONF
Otherwise something's gonna go wrong And comparisons are simple.
They just work the way they work.
NOTE CONF
And, uh, the bang, equal and equal equal are just
as simple as, well, um, it uses this is equal
NOTE CONF
function, which is a bit like the truthiness function.
Um, it does a little bit more than just, uh,
NOTE CONF
check for quality and we're in Java land.
So if those two happen to be strings, I couldn't
NOTE CONF
do string equal equal string.
You should know by now that that fails in Java
NOTE CONF
even when the strings are the same sometimes, so you
should always do string dot equals string.
NOTE CONF
So he's bundled that up into this function that does
both the truthiness check for him and chooses to use
NOTE CONF
the the dot equals instead of the equal equals to
keep that safe.
NOTE CONF
OK, a bit more details on on what things might
evaluate to.
NOTE CONF
I want you to recognise that as we're working through
our interpreter, decisions are coming up.
NOTE CONF
We're making decisions about how the language works and what
goes wrong in language design is that a compiler writer
NOTE CONF
or an interpreter writer keeps making these decisions without noting
that they've made the decisions or even realising that they've
NOTE CONF
made the decisions.
And then behaviour that is unspecified to the user has
NOTE CONF
a specification deep in the compiler.
And when the two don't line up, strange things happen.
NOTE CONF
Or a second person comes along and writes another compiler
and makes different decisions to that compiler writer.
NOTE CONF
And they got two slightly incompatible implementations of supposedly the
same language.
NOTE CONF
Yep, so we were jamming casts all over the place,
but now we go into what the runtime errors should
NOTE CONF
actually look like And so this wants to be.
This is not a scan error that scans fine.
NOTE CONF
It's not a PAS error.
It pas fine, but it's a runtime error because I
NOTE CONF
can't negate Muffin because it's not a number.
So he puts in a bunch of checks.
NOTE CONF
Whenever he's about to do an A cast, he checks
to see if that cast is safe.
NOTE CONF
So he's used a function called check number Operand that
says, um, I'm about to work on on one of
NOTE CONF
these nodes.
One of these, um, in this case I'm inside the
NOTE CONF
unary operator, Am I?
No, I'm inside the actual expression.
NOTE CONF
Just check that number Upper I if it's not of
the kind that I need.
NOTE CONF
If it's not a number, if it is a number,
just return.
NOTE CONF
If it's not a number, then throw one of these
brand new errors.
NOTE CONF
I just invented, um, and that goes over and over.
So this is the new runtime error he invented.
NOTE CONF
It goes in another class.
It's just a a small extension of the runtime exception,
NOTE CONF
noting that runtime exceptions don't need to be checked in
Java, so you you can throw them and they can
NOTE CONF
just crash the programme.
We would like to check them.
NOTE CONF
Um and he extends it just a little bit so
that he can keep track of the token that fired
NOTE CONF
that runtime expression.
And so then he's got a couple more checks for
NOTE CONF
He needs to check two operations that are both numbers,
Um and yeah, so that's this helper function here.
NOTE CONF
It checks on both the left and the right to
decide if their numbers We don't have a check for
NOTE CONF
strings because we're able to do just about everything.
Like there's not a string operator that we don't want
NOTE CONF
to do on numbers.
There's a number operator we don't want to do on
NOTE CONF
strings, but we're throwing these.
Oh, no, there's one.
NOTE CONF
Oh, that's the plus.
If you get plus and you've got string number, number
NOTE CONF
string, you gotta throw something.
Um, but he hasn't had to write an extra check
NOTE CONF
for that.
He's just been able to when he drops down through
NOTE CONF
a couple of instances of he's got a spot already
to put that through.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'm just gonna note and I'm gonna leave it
for the workshop to discuss more.
NOTE CONF
The fact that we were doing errors before just by
going locks dot error.
NOTE CONF
We were calling a static method on the locks class
to say, Oh, my powers are my scanner or my
NOTE CONF
Parsa have found an error Time to bail.
I'm just going to call that error method, um, and
NOTE CONF
move on.
We don't take that approach here.
NOTE CONF
Instead, we throw a runtime error and then the exceptions
machinery has to deal with it.
NOTE CONF
It's an interesting thought.
Why he does those two different approaches that's illuminating, that
NOTE CONF
we've covered enough for you to answer in the lecture.
So I'm gonna leave that so that you've got some
NOTE CONF
time to ponder over why it's exceptions here versus just
an error function elsewhere.
NOTE CONF
And that's in the workshops this week.
Alright, The last thing he does is just hook up
NOTE CONF
the interpreter, um, writes an interpret function which tries to
evaluate, catches any runtime errors and then uses a different
NOTE CONF
locks method to output that runtime error.
Um oh, notice he uses a string of fire here.
NOTE CONF
Um, this is a possible strange decision, so Java already
has a string I method built in.
NOTE CONF
It's called two string Every method, every object in the
language has a two string and so we could have
NOTE CONF
just done value 0.2 string here.
But he said, No, no, no, My, my, For some
NOTE CONF
reason, my interpreter needs its own two string.
And because I'm relying on Capital, B Bully and Capital
NOTE CONF
D double, um, where the two string is in that
class.
NOTE CONF
I can't change it if I want to adjust the
two string.
NOTE CONF
I've either got inherit from that class, and then I
make my own version of double.
NOTE CONF
Or I just write my own stringify function that knows
how to stringify everything in my language.
NOTE CONF
And I'll put all my logic in there.
He chooses the second one, so if it's a null,
NOTE CONF
he returns nil because he's got nil instead of null.
If it's a double, he does something special just to
NOTE CONF
make it match his language.
Otherwise, he does Just use the two string, he says.
NOTE CONF
All right.
No, no, those are my only special cases.
NOTE CONF
I'll just use the two string, OK, and there's the
bit in the locks code that just spits out the
NOTE CONF
runtime error.
Um, the reason he's got a separate function for that
NOTE CONF
is because one time errors have a token.
And so he just wants to grab that token and
NOTE CONF
output it as well and use a special notation so
he can see.
NOTE CONF
And then he he puts this flag has runtime error.
He used that flag before.
NOTE CONF
If it has pas error or has error, and it
just allows the interpreter to bail out and run again
NOTE CONF
Okey dokey And the rest of it's just stuff.
OK, so conceptually little, but a lot.
NOTE CONF
I mean, I say this in every lecture.
I do this all the time.
NOTE CONF
It's what computing is.
I'll say it again.
NOTE CONF
Um, like, I really want you to focus, um, on
this process, I went through here to make this diagram
NOTE CONF
because I just think that if you if you read,
if anyone's read that chapter already, it probably just went
NOTE CONF
past them like gobbledygook.
But with the context of what's really going on and
NOTE CONF
what we've got already in the system done diagrammatically that
I can kind of scan over and map my brain
NOTE CONF
to where everything goes makes so much more sense.
I'm not just skimming over and going.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, those are words.
Those words look correct.
NOTE CONF
I can't disagree with any of that.
Um, this is my understanding.
NOTE CONF
And the book is more like a reference material to
help me know.
NOTE CONF
Exactly.
What do I put in my visit?
NOTE CONF
Binary.
And my visit Unary.
NOTE CONF
Um and exactly what does it look like when I
mean, I'm interpreting one of these visitors.
NOTE CONF
Uh, I'm extending one of these visitors up here.
Now, In the workshops, you're asked to trace an evaluation.
NOTE CONF
So that was what I did early on.
I traced an evaluation.
NOTE CONF
It's all gone from my picture now because the trace
was a dynamic thing.
NOTE CONF
Um, but if anyone comes up with a really nice
way to trace evaluations that helps them understand, that'd be
NOTE CONF
great for us to share with others.
Right?
NOTE CONF
Seeing how other people internalise, A concept is very helpful
to seeing the subtleties of the concept.
NOTE CONF
If you haven't managed to find a way to internalise
it, you might be able to use theirs.
NOTE CONF
Um, but tracing it can mean scribbling all over the
board, rubbing things out, putting new things up.
NOTE CONF
It's a it's a dynamic process rather than a a
static one.
NOTE CONF
Really.
But that trace does happen on the abstract syntax tree.
NOTE CONF
It's the when I'm asking for a trace of an
evaluator.
NOTE CONF
I'm asking.
Show me how this abstract syntax tree became a single
NOTE CONF
value.
Take me through the steps.
NOTE CONF
One by one.
Good job.
NOTE CONF
Questions, questions, questions.
Right.
NOTE CONF
Everybody's going.
I'm definitely going to get some prizes for the rest
NOTE CONF
of this semester and start offering them to people who,
um, make my life the easiest.
NOTE CONF
Which normally means nodding and shaking and responding to me
in lectures.
NOTE CONF
You're my favourite people in the whole world, so I
should offer you some prizes.
NOTE CONF
Uh, So what do people want for prizes?
Chocolate.
NOTE CONF
Oh, man, we think bigger than that.
I'll get chocolates.
NOTE CONF
That's no problems.
Yeah, so I can't hear the what in the interpret
NOTE CONF
part.
So it just seems to be a bit louder.
NOTE CONF
What are you asking about?
Yeah, this except here.
NOTE CONF
Yeah.
So, mechanically, the way a visitor works is that an
NOTE CONF
expression is waiting for you to give it a visitor
object.
NOTE CONF
And then that visitor object goes whoosh across the tree.
So calling that accept method is how you get the
NOTE CONF
visitor onto the tree and boom, It just does its
business.
NOTE CONF
So as I said alternately we because the accept method
is sorry.
NOTE CONF
The evaluate method is written inside interpreter.
The parameter you send in is this.
NOTE CONF
It's the interpreter You're just defining.
But just to be clear, an alternative way to do
NOTE CONF
it from the locks file, for example would be to
go EX PR dot Accept new interpreter.
NOTE CONF
You can build the interpreter, send it immediately into the
accept method.
NOTE CONF
Same thing.
Oh, yeah?
NOTE CONF
Well, if you got ideas of things you want, surprise
it just ping me because I'm gonna go shopping.
NOTE CONF
And, uh And now you're on notice.
So keep making happy faces and sad faces and asking
NOTE CONF
questions like that question, which is a brilliant question.
And it's gonna be a totally subjective thing to judge
NOTE CONF
who gets my prize at the end of the year.
And for those of you at home wondering about turning
NOTE CONF
up, you don't get it.
I turn up.
NOTE CONF
These are my favourite people.
No, I'm joking.
NOTE CONF
I look like you all.
Oh, raspberry pi Cool.
NOTE CONF
P five P four P zero.
We can do better.
NOTE CONF
OK, so people are posting proper prizes.
Um all right.
NOTE CONF
Can I move the ipad out?
Yeah, I think it's mostly there, but again.
NOTE CONF
Reminder.
I mean, this is all in the recording.
NOTE CONF
If you want to go frame by frame through the
recording and copy my notes, go for it.
NOTE CONF
Um, but ultimately, I want you making your own version
of this that represents your internalised understanding.
NOTE CONF
Um, I don't think I can express this strongly enough
that at this point in learning computer of learning programming,
NOTE CONF
you're not learning facts and figures.
You're not learning techniques and skills.
NOTE CONF
You're generating an internal model of something in there, and
that's so hard to express.
NOTE CONF
But that's what teaching is.
So how and everybody's internal model is subtly different.
NOTE CONF
I can't impart one model from me to you, Uh,
which means my diagram.
NOTE CONF
Everyone's diagrams need to be slightly different.
This is one of the reasons UML is a failing
NOTE CONF
because UML says, Oh, there might.
There's one way to express the way people think about
NOTE CONF
this system.
There's not, and so UML ish is good, because it
NOTE CONF
if I stick to things that, like when I put
this is UML ish because, well, I, I failed on
NOTE CONF
my UML issues.
Um, I tried to be UML ish by putting a
NOTE CONF
line under something when it was a class and not
putting a line under it when it was an object.
NOTE CONF
But really, in my version, uh, I think I failed
on that.
NOTE CONF
That was class.
These are all classes, but I forgot to put things
NOTE CONF
under them.
Uh, but UML ish.
NOTE CONF
There's some things we agree on, like I agreed on
the open triangle meaning inheritance.
NOTE CONF
Um, And over here, I wasn't using open triangles because
these were relationships between objects, not inheritance relationships.
NOTE CONF
But this is all my own understanding, and you've got
to have your own and you've got to have something
NOTE CONF
as complex as this in your head at some time.
And I don't think it's possible to have something as
NOTE CONF
complex as that in your head unless you have something
as complex as that in some Written is what I
NOTE CONF
wanna say.
But that might be because I'm a gen X.
NOTE CONF
Um, written is what I need to represent my head.
You might be able to have some typed version that
NOTE CONF
represents your what's going, but I doubt it.
I.
NOTE CONF
I feel like the pen is the connection between the
conceptual understanding and the whatever's going on in my damn
NOTE CONF
iPad, it helps connect the two.
All right, enough of that.
NOTE CONF
Let's do prologue.
I'm excited for prologue.
NOTE CONF
Same three people are just making more faces.
Now the rest of you gotta make faces too.
NOTE CONF
But prologue is exciting.
Actually, prologue is one of the more interesting ones to
NOTE CONF
look at.
We only get to do one day from the book.
NOTE CONF
So I said, Just do Day one of prologue because
it gets pretty heavy pretty quick.
NOTE CONF
And, um, you know, you're noticing this course is fairly
packed.
NOTE CONF
When we put together the course, we didn't know how
many days out of the seven languages we'd be using
NOTE CONF
will we will everything else be easy and we can
do three days on each language?
NOTE CONF
No, there's plenty going on in the rest of the
course, so we we we're just doing the first day
NOTE CONF
of Prolock.
Let's go.
NOTE CONF
Alright.
Prologue is one of those languages you won't get the
NOTE CONF
you won't get the wow experience I got.
But prologue is one of those languages that gave me
NOTE CONF
a wow experience during my undergraduate.
There are a few experiences I don't know if you
NOTE CONF
have them where you just go?
Oh, my God, that's crazy.
NOTE CONF
One of them was when I learnt about, um, machine
code and cache missing.
NOTE CONF
And I was like, all of that's going on in
there.
NOTE CONF
It messed with my head for, like, weeks because just
understanding exactly how much goes on every time I press
NOTE CONF
a key, wh blew my brain.
But another one was the unification algorithm in pro prologue
NOTE CONF
and the the understanding that prologue is a computational model
of logic.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I'm just gonna show you prologue as a
computational model here.
NOTE CONF
Mostly people get taught the logic and then into prologue.
But we're just gonna go down the computational model and
NOTE CONF
then I'll try and match that over to a bit
of logic that we're not covering here and we can't
NOTE CONF
assume because I don't think I think I don't think
everyone in Comp 3000 has done D ma 237.
NOTE CONF
No, they haven't only the software engineers, so we can't
assume enough logic, but we'll touch on it.
NOTE CONF
I think I'll be able to explain to you why
it's interesting and enlighten you on something.
NOTE CONF
So this is a language that like we did IO
last week, which is an esoteric language that doesn't have
NOTE CONF
a huge audience or long history.
But, uh is an interesting design point.
NOTE CONF
Prologue is an esoteric language with a very long history,
and a lot of people have used it over the
NOTE CONF
years, and very few people still use it.
But those who do find it an invaluable tool co
NOTE CONF
prologue does something that other languages just don't do.
You can a reminder I don't know if we said
NOTE CONF
this early on, but just if I just explain the
concept of chewing completeness, no one's nodding or shaking.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna assume No, um, Alan Turing, back in
19 was twenties or thirties.
NOTE CONF
Well, in fact, Alonso church in the twenties wrote down,
um, a system that could compute everything that can be
NOTE CONF
computed.
Yeah, that was called the Lambda Calculus.
NOTE CONF
And in doing so, he disproved or he proved in
the negative the en scheen problem, which was the problem
NOTE CONF
was, can an algorithm compute everything that's logically true?
If I give it some axioms and just run it,
NOTE CONF
will it be able to say true, false, true false
for everything that flows from those axioms and in the
NOTE CONF
process of proving that you couldn't do that.
Alonso church invented the Lambda calculus, and the reason he
NOTE CONF
was able to prove it was because he could prove
that the Lambda Calculus could calculate everything that could be
NOTE CONF
calculated.
And he could prove that it was an analogue of
NOTE CONF
logic.
And so he proved that since the Lambda A can't
NOTE CONF
calculate, since there's some things the lambic A can't calculate,
there are some things logics can't work out.
NOTE CONF
But in that process of saying, this thing definitely calculates
everything that can be calculated, that's an interesting thing on
NOTE CONF
its own chewing It was a student of churches came
along and said, Look, that Lambda calculus is fine and
NOTE CONF
all, But if I wanted to build one of these,
I'd need to do it this way.
NOTE CONF
And he invented the chewing machine, which also can calculate
everything that can be calculated and then use that for
NOTE CONF
various things.
So any system that can calculate everything that can be
NOTE CONF
calculated is during complete, and most programming languages you know
of are chew incomplete, and what that means is, deep
NOTE CONF
down, theoretically their equivalent.
If you really wanted to go into battle for your
NOTE CONF
weird programming language.
You can do everything in that language that you can
NOTE CONF
do in C.
You can do everything in that language that you can
NOTE CONF
do in Java.
You can do right.
NOTE CONF
Some of them are getting really stupidly hard.
But there's a mathematical proof that your language can do
NOTE CONF
it.
Um, all the languages we're looking at in the seven
NOTE CONF
languages are you incomplete?
Uh, some of the little languages we saw early on,
NOTE CONF
um, aren't during complete, but most of them actually are.
You get during completeness very quickly, so even red jex
NOTE CONF
with a few extensions are during complete.
Um, the point being that what none of these languages
NOTE CONF
are better than each other because of what they can
do.
NOTE CONF
They can all do exactly the same thing.
They're better than each other because that part of the
NOTE CONF
problem space is hard in this language and that part
of the problem space is easy in this language, and
NOTE CONF
there is no language where the entire problem space is
easy.
NOTE CONF
So we're always looking for What's our problem space?
I'll find the language that best overlaps with that, and
NOTE CONF
I'll use that language, and I'll get some big wins
from that.
NOTE CONF
And so prologue is one of those These days a
lot of languages can get close enough to prologue, using
NOTE CONF
libraries and stuff that it's lost a lot of its
lustre.
NOTE CONF
But in the eighties and nineties, to do what prologue
did was a real hassle in other languages.
NOTE CONF
OK, but the thing it does is it takes declarative
statements and computes all the possible variants of those declarative
NOTE CONF
statements.
That could be true.
NOTE CONF
And hopefully you can just see that that sounds like
the description of the scheen problem I gave before.
NOTE CONF
That sounds like the description of what church was doing.
And that's right, because prologue is the programming language that's
NOTE CONF
skewing as closely to logic as it can.
So it's the programming language that really embodies the solution
NOTE CONF
to that problem, because prologue can't compute some logics some
logical statements exactly because of, uh, everything from before.
NOTE CONF
So you can almost think of this almost as kind
of a a core part of of programming distilled into
NOTE CONF
the language prologue.
There are lots of different implantations of prologue.
NOTE CONF
Uh, the one we gave you is SW I prologue,
I think here he uses the new prologue, Um and
NOTE CONF
so they'll slightly differ in their syntax and the things
they can do.
NOTE CONF
But the underlying concepts are the same.
Oh, I said declarative language.
NOTE CONF
What That means declarative language is a language that you
say what's going to happen, not how it's gonna happen.
NOTE CONF
That's a red X is an example of a declarative
language.
NOTE CONF
You're gonna say what it's gonna match, not how it's
gonna match it.
NOTE CONF
Uh, every other programming language you've used is a a
non declarative language because you've got to say where the
NOTE CONF
loops go and you've gotta say which variables get kept.
And you've gotta say all these things about how the
NOTE CONF
operation actually works.
As a prologue programmer, you tend to also internalise how
NOTE CONF
it works, but that's that's hidden.
So it's got quite a complex runtime and a simple
NOTE CONF
language because the how is in the the runtime OK
1972 which makes it a relatively old programming language.
NOTE CONF
There are a huge number of languages from the fifties
and sixties, and it's really made up of three things
NOTE CONF
facts, rules and queries.
So I've asked you in the tutorials to, um, implement
NOTE CONF
an SW a product.
These facts, we're gonna do some more complicated examples, but
NOTE CONF
by giving you an example, you don't have a copy
of you've gotta go from scratch.
NOTE CONF
Uh, bottom line is you've got Oh, sorry.
I've got the wrong thing on the screen again.
NOTE CONF
Um, yeah, yeah.
He's meant to stream the phone on the computer.
NOTE CONF
Yes.
I am sorry, Dylan, but I've caught up.
NOTE CONF
Um, so we set facts.
We set rules that are related to facts, and then
NOTE CONF
we ask you to query.
Basically, we're asking, Is this true or false?
NOTE CONF
So we give it a bunch of true things, a
bunch of rules that turn true things into other true
NOTE CONF
things and ask, Is this final thing true?
He compares it to rain man because it remembers a
NOTE CONF
bunch of facts and then spits it out at you.
That's not a bad comparison.
NOTE CONF
Um, OK, the syntax here with prologue is that and
this comes straight from logic is that you've got ground
NOTE CONF
symbols.
They're a bit like the ruby symbols, ground symbols that
NOTE CONF
start with a lower case and don't have any parameters
after them.
NOTE CONF
So, Wallace cheese Gromit, Wendolyn and sheep are just symbols.
They don't mean anything, but Wallace is different to cheese.
NOTE CONF
Gromit is different to Wallace.
They're all separate from each other and unique.
NOTE CONF
And when I write Wallace, I always mean the same
Wallace.
NOTE CONF
And when I write cheese, I always mean the same
cheese.
NOTE CONF
So you could think of that as 012134.
You know, just individual values.
NOTE CONF
Those are but the ground things are just definitely true.
If I write Wallace, it goes, Yeah, sure, Wallace Wallace
NOTE CONF
exists fine, but what you can do is relate two
things together.
NOTE CONF
So this syntax here says Wallace and Cheese are related
using the likes operator or the likes predicate.
NOTE CONF
So really, you can read it as Wallace likes cheese.
Gromes likes cheese.
NOTE CONF
Weo likes sheep, but really all it's doing.
And I've drawn on a picture, really, all it's doing,
NOTE CONF
saying Visualizer left that example.
The way I like to think of it is it's
NOTE CONF
just saying Wallace relates to cheese using likes so I
can use likes to get back and forth between Wallace
NOTE CONF
and Cheese R.
It relates to cheese with the likes and Gwendolyn Mean
NOTE CONF
sheep flex cool.
So those are That's why they're called relations because they
NOTE CONF
just relate two things together.
But give the relation a name as well, because I
NOTE CONF
could add to this Hates Wallace and whatever that crazy
dog's name was, I haven't seen these shows in a
NOTE CONF
long time.
Uh, but that would be just an entirely separate relationship
NOTE CONF
with those two things that are linked.
So the other thing you can then put in is
NOTE CONF
rules which are relationships, but where variables go where some
of the parts of the relationship are.
NOTE CONF
So I'm gonna be doing this on two screens at
once, but I'll flick over in a second.
NOTE CONF
So this rule here says in diagrammatic form, it says
X and Y are related using likes what?
NOTE CONF
What it says is that X and Y are related
as friends.
NOTE CONF
If X and Y are related as likes and what
Oh, that's X and Z.
NOTE CONF
I'm gonna write it first and then switch over because
I need to see both to write it correctly and
NOTE CONF
why and said are related to likes.
OK, so this statement here that's on the thing right
NOTE CONF
now is trying to say, Uh uh Actually, there's movies
around cos I'm writing it in the mathematical form, but
NOTE CONF
we're not in the math land yet.
Or maybe it'll now.
NOTE CONF
That statement that was on the book before says X
and Z are friends, so they're related by the friends
NOTE CONF
relationship.
If X and Z are related by a a likes
NOTE CONF
relationship and Y and Z, I did it wrong.
Y and Z are related by a like relationship, so
NOTE CONF
it's kind of saying, if you can find so can
we find any examples of this in the example we
NOTE CONF
got here?
Um, yes, because I can fill so I can fill
NOTE CONF
this in by saying, Look, I know that I've got
Gromit cheese using likes and I know I've got Wallace
NOTE CONF
Cheese using likes that works out.
So because I've got those I can fill in.
NOTE CONF
Wallace Gromit, his friends cool.
That's what prologue does, and that is how first auto
NOTE CONF
logic works.
And so prologue is just being first auto logic.
NOTE CONF
So it's a syntax for making statements like this and
because you can put variables in the statements.
NOTE CONF
What prologue also does for you is I just by
I found one that matched But Prologue's runtime guarantees to
NOTE CONF
find every possible match in your system.
So if I also had Wendolyn likes cheese, prologue guarantees
NOTE CONF
me that it will find Wallace's friends with Gromit.
Wallace is friends with Wendolyn.
NOTE CONF
Gromit is friends with Gwendolyn guarantees to find them all
just from that one extra fact, I added.
NOTE CONF
And that's what I mean by putting in the what,
but not the how.
NOTE CONF
We don't need to know how it finds all those
possible matches, but it does.
NOTE CONF
So it's a logic system because if all of the
facts I put down are true statements and all of
NOTE CONF
the rules I put down are valid.
Logical.
NOTE CONF
Uh, what's the I looking for?
Not plus the word assertions or progressions or rules or
NOTE CONF
they're valid in logic.
Then all of the facts that will come out are
NOTE CONF
also true.
It only finds true facts.
NOTE CONF
It doesn't find false facts.
False facts.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no, I lied.
It doesn't guarantee to find every possible one.
NOTE CONF
Uh, this is one of the subtleties of prologue, but
let's just pretend it guarantees to find every possible one.
NOTE CONF
That's its aim.
Its aim is to find every possible true one and
NOTE CONF
its aim also is to say, If I can't find
that, then it's false in my system, OK, so you
NOTE CONF
tend to put these things in a file.
I'm not 100% sure what this bit does.
NOTE CONF
Oh, no, That says X is not equal to Y,
so that's stopping it from finding Wallace.
NOTE CONF
Wallace is friends with Wallace, and Gromit is friends with
Gromit because that's also something that should come out of
NOTE CONF
my system.
Uh, if I didn't have that statement in there, so
NOTE CONF
I put those in a file.
And then when I load up prologue, I load up
NOTE CONF
that file and then I can ask queries like in
this case, I'll ask the query.
NOTE CONF
Does Wallace like sheep?
And it'll say no because it can't find the statements
NOTE CONF
to back that up If I added and I wouldn't
be able to get it still, but it asks if
NOTE CONF
I ask, Does Gromit like cheese?
It'll say Yes, because I've got that statement in my
NOTE CONF
facts.
And if I ask, is Wallace friends with Gromit?
NOTE CONF
It'll say yes, because it's able to find that not
directly as a fact, but via these other rules.
NOTE CONF
And finally I think he shows off, does he?
No.
NOTE CONF
If I ask, I can ask the system friend Gromit.
X.
NOTE CONF
So I can say, um I.
I wanna know everyone who can be a friend of
NOTE CONF
Gromit.
It will go one by one and give me all
NOTE CONF
the possible answers.
OK, so he's got another example here he does a
NOTE CONF
similar thing, but now he fills in the blanks.
So this is the example of filling in the blanks
NOTE CONF
where the syntax for it is Yeah, the food.
He's got a a syntax saying, um, I got a
NOTE CONF
bunch of facts.
What things go under the savoury bucket?
NOTE CONF
A key thing in prologue is that anything that starts
with a lower case letter is treated as a fact.
NOTE CONF
Anything that's got an uppercase letter is treated as a
variable.
NOTE CONF
So I was using capital X and Capital Y, and
that's what people normally use.
NOTE CONF
But by doing capital W what he's saying, I'm not
telling you the fact that what relates to savoury I'm
NOTE CONF
asking you in that slot where I've got the capital.
W.
NOTE CONF
What?
What facts will fire up and be true for that
NOTE CONF
one.
So I'll show you that?
NOTE CONF
Um was that the end of day one?
And did we do a bit more?
NOTE CONF
Uh, this bit was on day two.
Oh, yeah, it is.
NOTE CONF
We jump over to day two and then we do
the I'll just get to the end to make sure
NOTE CONF
I know what I'm doing.
Oh, no, this is all day one.
NOTE CONF
OK, ok, let's have a look at the example.
I'll load up my STW I prologue, and I'll put
NOTE CONF
some facts in.
I gotta think of a new thing to do.
NOTE CONF
Are we in the right thing?
We are not reopen in container.
NOTE CONF
What?
No.
NOTE CONF
Reopen this 10, it's already open.
OK, OK.
NOTE CONF
SW IP L loads up.
So with prologue, you normally pull in your fax from
NOTE CONF
a file.
But if I want to write my fax myself, uh,
NOTE CONF
I can do it with a special syntax called a
cert.
NOTE CONF
Um, but I've just got to put between those parentheses,
the thing I want to assert.
NOTE CONF
So I just think that's a bit of, um, boilerplate.
Um, so it's right.
NOTE CONF
What's the fact that we can put in?
Um, we can say we can convert strings to tokens
NOTE CONF
and we can say that we can convert tokens to
a STS, and we can assert that we can convert
NOTE CONF
a STS to values.
That's what we did today's lecture.
NOTE CONF
So I can ask, Can I convert strings to values?
And at the moment the system says I can't because
NOTE CONF
it's actually only got three facts.
The only relationships it's got is that string relates to
NOTE CONF
token.
Token relates to a ST, and a ST relates to
NOTE CONF
values.
There's nothing in my system that tells it that that's
NOTE CONF
a transitive relationship.
But if I assert that, Oh, I gotta move for
NOTE CONF
everyone else if I also assert that and I'm just
gonna have to get my syntax right here, um, just
NOTE CONF
gonna remind myself of exactly what they did.
But this is GNU prologue, but I think mine's the
NOTE CONF
same.
I need the colon equals.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, So if I assert that I can convert X
to Y any time Colin equals AC, dash C dash
NOTE CONF
anytime I can convert X to Z and convert Z
to Y who I wonder if I'm not allowed to
NOTE CONF
assert that there an instantiated argument expected found.
Convert two and argument.
NOTE CONF
All right, I can try putting it in a file
in case that's what I need.
NOTE CONF
So I'll control D out of that, and I will
CD dot dot and I'm KDAR prologue CD prologue and
NOTE CONF
I touch lecture, and then I will look to she
doesn't find it.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I don't like the way visual studio refuses to
play nice on that one.
NOTE CONF
Um, bit of prologue code.
Match it up here, so I'm just gonna put those
NOTE CONF
back in here.
So I had convert string to tokens.
NOTE CONF
I had convert tokens to a TS convert a STS
to hell.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, I'm just gonna That's tokens.
That's a single A ST, and an a ST converts
NOTE CONF
to a value.
And then I wanted to say I can convert X
NOTE CONF
to Y if I can convert X to Z and
convert Z to Y.
NOTE CONF
All right, let's see if that works.
Oh, we're already in there.
NOTE CONF
Um OK, I think it accepted my file.
Yeah, OK, so I'd accepted my file now and I
NOTE CONF
can try out the obvious one.
That definitely works.
NOTE CONF
I can try out, uh, string to value, and it
can do that one now because it's gone via that
NOTE CONF
rule.
a few times to get there.
NOTE CONF
I don't know exactly how it got there, but those
declarative rules should give this answer.
NOTE CONF
And so it does.
Finally, I can do convert, uh, string to anything.
NOTE CONF
And it tells me Well, one of the possible things
you can convert a string to is a token.
NOTE CONF
And if I ah, it's not another one, what do
I ask for?
NOTE CONF
I semi colon, um, I'll restart that one for you.
So now I said, Convert string.
NOTE CONF
But the thing on the rates are a variable.
I'm not gonna tell you what it says.
NOTE CONF
Well, I can fill that in with token.
That's valid.
NOTE CONF
I can fill that in with an A ST That's
valid.
NOTE CONF
I can fill it in with a value that's valid.
Um, but that's the last one I can fill that
NOTE CONF
in with Cool.
Yep.
NOTE CONF
Right now, as an interesting side, this stack limit, the
error that we just got is something that all prologue
NOTE CONF
programmes unfortunately have to know about.
Remember I said declarative languages.
NOTE CONF
You don't want to think about the run time.
You just wanna write the declarations and have it work.
NOTE CONF
One of the things we learned over the years as
programming language people is that you can never hide the
NOTE CONF
run time from the programmer.
You can't shift complexity in the run time and think
NOTE CONF
you've saved the programmer effort.
All you've done is just give them the job of
NOTE CONF
understanding the run time as well.
Sometimes that's still the right thing to do to separate
NOTE CONF
concerns whatever.
But PERL is a classic example of that.
NOTE CONF
This one gave me a stack error because I wrote
a left recursive convert rule and the way Prologues search
NOTE CONF
so prologue ultimately searches for answers.
It takes its existing facts well, it takes the query
NOTE CONF
you gave it and just expands it using rules and
fills in the gaps using facts and creates this gigantic
NOTE CONF
tree that's got every possible rule application and every possible
fact application and then tells you all of the parts
NOTE CONF
it found that don't have variables in it.
Cool.
NOTE CONF
But by writing a rule like I wrote it by
writing that rule when I wrote String X, what prologue
NOTE CONF
did was it said OK, well, I know I got
a I've got a convert string tokens.
NOTE CONF
That's one expansion I could do but because of that
rule.
NOTE CONF
I've also got this other expansion I could do, which
is convert string Z and convert Z.
NOTE CONF
X.
That's another way I could answer this question and it
NOTE CONF
says OK, well, I mean, I found one answer here,
but I'm gonna keep searching.
NOTE CONF
And so it goes and says, Well, what what can
I do for this one?
NOTE CONF
Oh, I found convert string tokens again and I found
convert string Z prime and convert the Rx.
NOTE CONF
And he goes, OK, well, I found another answer, but
it's actually the same answer as before, so I won't
NOTE CONF
give it to you twice.
Um, but we've got one answer discovered we cont, we
NOTE CONF
continually rediscover it, but that's OK.
Um, I'll keep going and it will just keep going
NOTE CONF
forever.
Right?
NOTE CONF
You can see that this path here we'll just continue
forever and ever and ever and ever.
NOTE CONF
Um and we didn't even get to asking it.
What happens if I try and expand this one?
NOTE CONF
And then what happens if I try and expand this
one so important for the prologue programmer is to know
NOTE CONF
how it processes that expansion because if it chooses to
the expansion breadth first, which you know all about cos
NOTE CONF
you've done in 2010.
It will find every correct answer and it will not
NOTE CONF
go down any infinite holes.
This is a cool, theoretical trick.
NOTE CONF
And if it goes depth first it might miss some
answers and it might get stuck in an infinite hole.
NOTE CONF
Can you guess which one fo does?
It would be smart, wouldn't it?
NOTE CONF
It doesn't.
It does depth.
NOTE CONF
Um, the reason it does depth first.
And this is actually a fun thing to go back
NOTE CONF
and look at in your comp 2010, which probably wasn't
discussed back then.
NOTE CONF
But here's the thing.
Breadth.
NOTE CONF
First the, um the what do we call it?
The frontier of the breadth.
NOTE CONF
First search gets bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and can get huge.
NOTE CONF
So the amount of memory required to keep track of
the entire frontier on a breadth first search is theoretically
NOTE CONF
infinite.
So you would run out of Ra M.
NOTE CONF
You wouldn't.
So yeah, whereas the the frontier for a depth first
NOTE CONF
search is fixed at a much smaller number because you
always replace one with one, you don't replace one with
NOTE CONF
well, less often replace one with phone.
So in practise, back in the eighties, when they were
NOTE CONF
doing prologue, they were hitting that memory wall way before
they were hitting their stack wall.
NOTE CONF
And so they went, No, no depth.
First will let us see more.
NOTE CONF
And now this day, with so much more Ra M,
maybe we might choose to do breadth 1st 1st, but
NOTE CONF
we would still hit a ra M wall because we
would ultimately run out of Ra M space.
NOTE CONF
So the depth first has the downside that there's infinite,
possibly an infinite hole.
NOTE CONF
Eventually, you hit your stack limit and you find out
you're an infant hog.
NOTE CONF
The breath first has the problem that you might run
out of memory, and they just chose a different place
NOTE CONF
in the trade off back in the day.
So the prologue programmers have to know that it looks
NOTE CONF
step first because then they have to know that they
can't write a convert rule like mine, or it's gonna
NOTE CONF
very quickly go down that hole.
So they write their rules in ways that don't quite
NOTE CONF
so fast go down the hole.
It's exactly the same problem we had with our left
NOTE CONF
recursive Parsa, and we just rephrased it so that it
wouldn't do left recursion.
NOTE CONF
It would do it a different way.
We were just forcing that Parsa to do a different
NOTE CONF
search of all the possible spaces.
We can do the same trick in prologue, and in
NOTE CONF
fact, prologue's a really great tool for writing PAS because
it searches the space of everything that's possible.
NOTE CONF
OK, now that probably is enough on pro Oh, no
unification.
NOTE CONF
We're not going past unification and then we'll still in
prologue.
NOTE CONF
So how the heck does this work?
So we've done.
NOTE CONF
We've seen the search part of prologue, but another important
part of prologue is this unification.
NOTE CONF
So I did it in my own head and you
believed me.
NOTE CONF
I'm just scrolling on here, but then I'll jump over.
I'll switch back over here and show you.
NOTE CONF
So the book explains it in one way, and I'm
explaining it in a slightly different way.
NOTE CONF
Sorry back on this one, when I did this part
and I said, This rule is valid for this rule.
NOTE CONF
Ultimately, what happens is that the system looks for its
query.
NOTE CONF
This is its one query and then it goes through
every fact that it already knows.
NOTE CONF
And if a fact unifies is the phrase they use,
then it's valid.
NOTE CONF
So these two must have unified.
I'm just gonna show you what unification looks like.
NOTE CONF
We can think of unification just as matching.
No, I don't know who you are.
NOTE CONF
And that's it.
Um, Optim.
NOTE CONF
When I wanted to do X, I was gonna try
it against every possible fact I knew.
NOTE CONF
And one of the rules, I one of the ones
I was gonna try it against was.
NOTE CONF
And so it's not hard for us to see that
these unify same same.
NOTE CONF
And that's a variable.
And that's a thing.
NOTE CONF
And I go, Yeah, cool, fine.
That process of saying each of the non variables have
NOTE CONF
to be the same, and the variables can be converted
to whatever they need to be.
NOTE CONF
That's unification.
That's all it is.
NOTE CONF
Um, but there's a formal algorithm for unification that is
general sought, beautiful and correct.
NOTE CONF
So this process here, where we're just doing one thing,
it's actually quite easy to make a unification work.
NOTE CONF
But when there's more than one variable, um, things can
get trickier when there's more than one term.
NOTE CONF
Things can get trickier, but one of those AHA moments
I had was spending six months learning prologue or maybe
NOTE CONF
four months learning prologue and then learning how its unification
algorithm works and just realising how simple and impressive it
NOTE CONF
is to still be as powerful as letting me do
everything I wanted to do in prologue.
NOTE CONF
But for us, you just think of it as matching.
Does it match?
NOTE CONF
And you go, Yeah, variable matches against anything.
That's, uh then that's fine, but they talk about the
NOTE CONF
unification in there.
That's the key.
NOTE CONF
So the key to to to prologue is the search
and the unification and one thing prologue programmers love to
NOTE CONF
do because it happens all the time.
So I just described that, uh, Prologues really good for
NOTE CONF
parses as well.
Um, pasa generators aren't exactly search plus unification, but they're
NOTE CONF
close.
In the real world of programming, people are constantly doing
NOTE CONF
search plus unification, and they don't realise they're doing search
plus unification.
NOTE CONF
They just get given a problem by the boss and
they try and solve it, and they spend months and
NOTE CONF
months and months on it, and they finally come to
the answer that they've gotta expand out the tree every
NOTE CONF
time one of the rules applies.
And then they've gotta track down the parts of the
NOTE CONF
tree where all the rules are dispatched and they go,
OK, that's the one.
NOTE CONF
So maybe you're doing DNF Look up or something.
That might be something that works that way, or I
NOTE CONF
don't know.
I'm just making things up now, but over and over,
NOTE CONF
it'll happen in the real world that the problem you're
actually solving is search plus unification.
NOTE CONF
So by knowing you see the problem state and you
go to yourself Oh, that's just search plus uni plus
NOTE CONF
unification.
You don't have to solve it from scratch.
NOTE CONF
You can say, Oh, jeez, I'll just either use prologue
or use whatever prologue library is in my language and
NOTE CONF
just do search plus unification.
And as someone who studied prologue, which you're not, unfortunately,
NOTE CONF
you just at the start you go.
Oh, I better be careful when I use that library
NOTE CONF
to use depth first or breadth first, based on my
needs.
NOTE CONF
This is a classic example where something like prologue encompasses
a huge class of problems that come up over and
NOTE CONF
over in programming.
And so, by learning that language, you equip yourself to
NOTE CONF
solve those problems in all the other domains they appear
even if you never use prolock.
NOTE CONF
But Prolock is exposed to you about search and unification
and the depth first versus breadth.
NOTE CONF
First thing is valuable to you in whatever environment in
which you have to do search plus unification.
NOTE CONF
OK, That's everything I wanted to chat about today.
Is there anything else people would like to ask me?
NOTE CONF
We've got a few.
I'm just gonna get my suggestions up over here so
NOTE CONF
I can see Where's the where did it go?
Oh, over there.
NOTE CONF
Wendle does like sheep, but I don't know what the
point of that is.
NOTE CONF
The context for that, Um, any other questions people want
to ask?
NOTE CONF
Well, we can try it because I don't know, off
the top of my head, Let's try it.
NOTE CONF
That's going to come down to the language.
Implementation.
NOTE CONF
Um, so I'm gonna do convert, cos that's what I
got loaded up here, so no.
NOTE CONF
Yep.
So they're directional in the system, So Yep, that's a
NOTE CONF
good question.
So if I wanted them to be bidirectional, I just
NOTE CONF
have to add a rule, right?
I have to add the rule that says Convert X.
NOTE CONF
Why, whenever convert YX and then it will be traditional.
Yeah, yeah, This is sorry.
NOTE CONF
This is more A question on is a good way
of thinking about for a long distance If you're a
NOTE CONF
math, if you're a mathematician who's done sets and relations,
that's exactly what you think of it as.
NOTE CONF
But 99% of people are programmers moving into the world
of logic.
NOTE CONF
Um, you'll get tripped up on different things than the
programmers get tripped up on.
NOTE CONF
But that is what it's trying to model.
Yeah, that's it.
NOTE CONF
Yep, I guess.
Speaking of intuition, would we say in patients like when
NOTE CONF
it says making both sides?
Yeah, now, that's a very good question.
NOTE CONF
Let's see if I can answer it.
How is unification different from assignment?
NOTE CONF
It's not in any of these examples, but the key
difference is that when a variable is repeated in uni,
NOTE CONF
so you could never do a variable being repeated in
assignment just because of the way mechanically, you think of
NOTE CONF
assignment working, so I'm gonna contrive an example that falls
down somewhere else.
NOTE CONF
just to show you syntactically what?
I mean, if I wanted to say XX uh, so
NOTE CONF
sorry.
I'll write the the equivalent to this might be something
NOTE CONF
like, uh if I wanted to write this as an
assignment.
NOTE CONF
There are languages where I could write things like convert
String.
NOTE CONF
X equals convert.
Sorry, String token.
NOTE CONF
And I might understand that as meaning X equals token.
Fair enough.
NOTE CONF
That's Assi.
That's what you mean by assignment.
NOTE CONF
It would be nonsensical for me to write an equivalent
version of this one with two X's on there, but
NOTE CONF
in unification, that's totally possible.
And the unification algorithm should reject this and it does.
NOTE CONF
And you go, OK, that's fine.
I just asked you to assign two things that aren't
NOTE CONF
compatible, but that's a start to answering that question.
It's saying, Yeah, it is like assignment.
NOTE CONF
But what if you try to assign the same thing
twice in one step?
NOTE CONF
What should happen or in this case, fail?
What happens if two things end up being assigned twice
NOTE CONF
because of the way unification has to weasel into all
the parts?
NOTE CONF
What should happen then?
What order should the should the things be done in
NOTE CONF
The answer in unification is that it happens simultaneously.
All these this attempt to unify this X and Y
NOTE CONF
happens simultaneously and then fail.
And finally there is.
NOTE CONF
Unification also deals with a situation like this.
Where should a variable X match against a variable X
NOTE CONF
and unification?
The answer is no.
NOTE CONF
And there's a theoretical reason and demonstrate a reason why
that should be no.
NOTE CONF
Whereas an assignment, a variable being equal to itself just
means do nothing.
NOTE CONF
Uh So, yes, it's a very It's a very good
point that it's a lot like assignment assignment on structures
NOTE CONF
of things.
Yeah, and so the reason, Uh so it's called unification
NOTE CONF
In prologue.
These terms might are all subtly different in computer unification
NOTE CONF
matching, which is what we would call it if we
were doing a a fancy switch statement or something.
NOTE CONF
And then also assignment because you can do structured assignment
in some languages, so structured assignment can work.
NOTE CONF
They they're they, they they're all approaching a similar problem
with a different choice at the edge cases.
NOTE CONF
And the key difference is that neither of these will
allow repeated variables, and this will all other questions.
NOTE CONF
OK, have fun I'll see you next week or around
the traps.
NOTE CONF
I might go to a class or two and and
so far my suggestions are raspberry pies, which I can
NOTE CONF
definitely do.
The new Raspberry Pi fives are out.
NOTE CONF
Would you want it with a controller so that you
could play games on it?
NOTE CONF
What do you want it so that you can do
with a bread board so that you can do electronics?
NOTE CONF
OK, cool.
Let me write that down.
NOTE CONF
Pie and chocolate, please.
All right, now we've got Carlie.
NOTE CONF
Carlie, Carlie!
Carlie!
NOTE CONF
Carlie Carlie for this.
Ah, the times are gone.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, thanks.
I'll update that those times always go wrong.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, because I thought like the practise has not started
yet.
NOTE CONF
I'll just get rid of the enable.
It's just open all the time.
NOTE CONF
51 is sorry.
Covers.
NOTE CONF
Great.
Thank you so much.
NOTE CONF
Yo, yo.
Hey.
NOTE CONF
Sorry.
You good?
NOTE CONF
I had planned to come in this morning and I
was just a wreck this morning.
NOTE CONF
I've had a thought.
Tell me what you think of a thought.
NOTE CONF
What if you just didn't do it?
I want you to pop this on and we'll switch
NOTE CONF
it on now.
because it'll start recording so somewhere it'll start recording automatically
NOTE CONF
at five past the hour.
By that clock.
NOTE CONF
Yeah, you You can switch it off and then just
don't forget to switch it.
NOTE CONF
No.
OK, so we might just leave it on, OK?
NOTE CONF